- Hi everyone.
I'm Maurice Samuels, the
director of the Yale program
for the study of antisemitism.
And it's my great pleasure
to welcome you here today
to the next installment
in our Benjamin and Barbara
Zucker Lecture Series.
Before I hand it over to
my colleague, Carolyn Dean
who will introduce today's speaker.
I just want to say a word
about how it's going to work today.
This is a webinar format
so the audience members
are not visible or audible
but we do want to hear from you.
So if you have questions
and we hope you do
please submit them at any time
including during the talk itself,
using the Q and A function
at the bottom of your screen
don't use the chat and
don't raise your hand.
We use the Q and A function only
at the bottom of the screen.
And then I will filter those questions
to Professor Ben-Ghiat
during the question section.
So now without further ado
I will turn it over to my colleague.
Carolyn Dean, who is the Charles J. Stille
Professor of History and French
at Yale University to
present today's speaker.
- Thank you, Maurice.
Welcome everyone.
I'm delighted to have this opportunity
to introduce Professor Ruth Ben-Ghiat.
Ruth Ben-Ghiat is a historian an educator
and a commentator on fascism,
authoritarian leaders
and propaganda and the
threats these presents
to democracies around the world.
Professor, she is a professor
of history and Italian studies
at NYU or New York university.
She's the author of seven
books and many essays
among them, I should say two
extremely important books,
"Fascist Modernities: Italy, 1922-1945"
and "Italian Fascism's Empire Cinema".
Also an important second project
dealing with Italian empire
and she's published obviously much more,
including in CNN, The New
Yorker, the Washington Post.
Now, she's here to discuss with us
themes from her newest book,
"Strongmen, Mussolini to the Present",
which just came out last year with Norton
and this the "Strongmen" examines
the authoritarian
playbook illiberal leaders
have used for a century.
So with that, please join me in welcoming
Professor Ruth Ben-Ghiat.
Thank you.
Thank you to everyone
for coming and to Carolyn
and to Maurice Samuels
for inviting me to speak.
So "Strongmen" comes out of my efforts
at civic education in a way,
it's a book written for the public.
And so I want to start by
talking about why I wrote it.
And one of the reasons was a reaction
to a rather intense period
of revisionism of history
by the global right to
minimize the violence
of the authoritarian past.
We see leaders, rehabilitating
autocratic predecessors
as Putin's putting up statues of Stalin
but Russian scholars who
write the wrong things
about Stalin's mass graves are imprisoned.
You can't talk about the Nazi
Soviet pact in Russia anymore,
nor a Polish collaboration
with the Holocaust and Poland,
both scenario in Brazil and
many others on the global right
falsely claimed that fascism
was a left wing phenomenon.
And this has done of
course to tar the left
with fascist violence and leave
the right with clean hands.
And this is a very common
talking point around the world.
And when we see like a rally
that the far right proud boys held
in the States in September, 2020
I'll show you a slide later.
Not only you have the
Confederate flag, of course
but you have proud boys
wearing a t-shirt that says,
"Pinochet did nothing wrong"
referring to the Chilean dictator.
So I really felt that to
understand what's going on today
including those who
spread hatred in America
we need a historical
and global perspective
on a century of authoritarianism.
And of course, bringing this global lens
that historical lens to bear on America
was crucial to this book project.
And it was attempt by me in American
to understand what was happening
to us under Donald Trump.
And it's the first book
that came out in November
just after the election,
a week after the election.
It's the first book to
place the Trump presidency
in the context of a century
of authoritarian history.
And I had written many things predicting
he would follow a kind
of authoritarian playbook
referring to 21st
century authoritarianism,
where you come to office via elections
and you manipulate elections
to try and stay there.
And so it was intended
as a kind of warning
that no country is immune
from the lure of leaders
who appear on the scene and
legitimize existing extremist
and anti-democratic tendencies
and make a racism part of their platforms.
And legitimate is also the idea
that violence is a way to cause problems
to deal with enemies of the state
and to move history forward.
And we saw this coming to
a climax in January six.
So the book is divided into three periods:
the fascist period, the
age of military coups
and what I call new authoritarianism
which starts with the end of the cold war.
And I chose to focus mainly
on right-wing strongmen.
So I'm just giving you the context now
in part, because of my
training and fascism,
and it was also interested
in individuals who damage
or destroy democracies rather
than kind of inherited power
as in China or North Korea
but clearly these right,
as in personality, cults
and tactics of violence,
the right and the left wing
authoritarian things unfold in dialogue.
And I make that clear in the book.
And the core of the book are chapters on
what I call the authoritarian playbook
the tools of rule and
propaganda corruption virility,
the myth of national
greatness and violence.
And each one goes over a hundred years
and this was quite
challenging to write it.
At times I had wished
I had just done a biographical
approach, you know
everything on Mussolini,
everything on Hitler
but I wanted the reader to be able to see
for example, with propaganda,
what changes and what stays
the same over a hundred years.
And just to define my terms
I use the term strongmen
to refer to a leaders
who are a subset of authoritarians
who use all these tools
including masculinity or machismo
as a tool of political legitimacy.
So the virility is very important
in how they relate to their own people
and also in their relationships
with foreign despots
whether they actually wrecked democracy
or as happens in the 21st century,
kind of they're aspirational
and they damage it.
So it's not a book of comparative politics
where I'm saying Trump is like Hitler,
but a history that traces through lines,
through a hundred years
like the fascist who fled to Franco Spain
and then went on to Pinochet's Chile,
and then on some of them
onto Berlusconi Italy
or the influential position
of Opus Dei Catholics in
the governments of Franco,
Pinochet, Berlusconi, and Trump.
And of course, the groups that recur
as the strongmen's
victims: nomadic peoples
whether the Bedouin of
Libya or Roma people,
religious minorities, of
course, Jews and Muslims
and Jehovah's Witnesses
who are famously persecuted
by Hitler, but perhaps less known.
They're also persecuted by Putin.
So against this backdrop, I want to talk
about the myth of national greatness
in particular the
contrast between this idea
of that the strongmen will
bring the nation to greatness
and the chaos and destruction
that these States have caused.
And it's really amazing how
the myth of authoritarianism
as efficient and productive,
the idea that the trains run on time
with Mussolini, it's really endured.
It's been hard to fell this myth
and or the idea that Franco
and Pinochet brought
stability to their countries.
And of course, antisemitism
recurs in this tragic history
of wastes of life, of through genocides
through loss of human and
financial resources of the state,
through killings, through
forced exiles, you know,
hundreds of thousands of
people going into exile
through capital flight and acts of plunder
against demonized categories
of people, you know
plundered bodies, plundered
bank accounts, and property.
So I also want to talk
about personality cults
and the idea that the strongmen alone
can bring the nation to greatness
and the projects of national purification
that come with this.
And some of these,
if you look at the big course
of a hundred years of history,
some of these are
counter-revolutionary projects
against leftists.
So you have from the
fascist to the cold war
leaders like Pinochet up
through Bolsonaro and Trump.
And the rhetoric, for
example, of William Barr
who was attorney general until recently
with the police and the
way he talks about enemies
and on our case jurisdictions
that very much draws on this lineage.
And of course also perceived
racial and demographic
emergencies due to the
decline of white births
and possible quote invasions
of the country by non-whites.
This is something that recurs
with very similar rhetoric
from the fascist up to Orban
in Hungary and in Brazil today
among the global right.
And of course, where
demographic concerns surface
so does anti-Semitism.
So I'm going to share my screen now
And just get rid of this.
And here's just a slide
from the proud boys rally
because I really think it's important
to keep this global reach of the far right
as it's manifesting in
America and American elsewhere
with antisemitism, with racism.
And it's too for us to forget
about the other side of things.
And but it's all of a whole
and I think we need to see this
in more of a global the framework.
So one of the things that recurs is
why did these figures hold an appeal
at certain times in history?
And one recurrence that comes
over and over in the book
is that when countries have been through
a period of a lot of
social immense pushing
could be gender equity, racial equity
it could be workers'
rights, secularization.
The times when male authority
and male status feel threatened.
This is when the idea of
the leader as omnipotent
and infallible compensates
for these anxieties.
He is the anchor of the nation.
He is the embodiment of the
aspiration to national purity.
And one dynamic and those of you familiar
with the fascist years,
this will be familiar.
It's very important that the
strongman doesn't just embody,
he doesn't just represent the nation
like a democratic leader.
He embodies the nation,
he takes into himself
the sorrows, the victim
hood of the nation.
So he physically embodies it.
And this is an interesting,
this is by pro Trump
painter, Jon McNaughton
called "Respect the Flag".
And it's about the
controversy over NFL kneeling
to protest police racism and brutality.
But what I would like you to see here
is the way that Trump has depicted,
he's quiet he's stricken.
He shows emotions that indeed the
famously non-empathetic
Trump didn't really have,
but he's clutching the
tattered flag to himself.
Again, he's full of sorrow.
And so he represents the
emotions that the nation perhaps
can't express for itself.
And so all of these figures
are able to, this was of course
famously said of Hitler, that
when he would give speeches
he was expressing things that people felt
they didn't know how
to express themselves.
And this becomes important
when minorities are persecuted
and the leader is the embodiment
of kind of the good nation.
Here's another to do with the
fantasies of national purity.
So of course they are
acclaimed from below.
They are there by the will of the people.
And this is true, whether they're elected
or whether as in Qaddafi's case,
they come in by military coup.
But they also are getting
inspiration from divine sources.
So here is a classic, this
is both these phenomenon
are represented in this billboard.
It's with you, we embrace glory.
This is the people telling Gaddafi
from below that he elevates them.
And yet he's looking heavenward
and Gaddafi used to stop in
the middle of his speeches
and look up to the heavens
as though he was getting
divine inspiration.
So strongmen national purity projects
usually leverage three
separate timeframes.
One is a utopia and of course
the desire for a pristine and
perfect national community
has justified state racism, antisemitism,
all of these kind of racial
States that's obvious.
But nostalgia is also very
important for better times
and so it's never just
making the nation great.
It's making the nation great again.
So Mussolini had the Roman empire,
Erdogan in Turkey today looks
back to the Ottoman empire
and various other examples.
The Spanish empire for Franco, of course
Hitler had alien civilization.
And today the global right
often makes reference
to Christian dumb, whether
it's in Brazil or in Hungary
or in Italy harking
back to the middle ages
to defend the kind of
white European heritage
seen as besieged by migrants, by Jews.
And here we have of course Soros
is the international symbol of that
could be indigenous peoples
all of these peoples at once, right?
So this is a propaganda campaign
and repetitions very
important in propaganda.
Don't let Soros have the last laugh.
And so we're going to
encounter this again,
the Jew who is not only
polluting the purity
but it's also somehow
exploiting the nation.
And this goes through a hundred years
of authoritarian history.
So I want to just talk for this audience,
you're probably more familiar
with a Nazi anti-Semitism.
So I'm want to just talk a little bit
about the fascia Italian fascist version
and show you some of this propaganda
And years before Hitler came to power.
Mussolini started talking in the 1920s
about a racial emergency.
He said that, you know, cradles were empty
and cemeteries were full and
quote yellow and Brown people
were at the doors and there
was this kind of demographic
and racial emergency.
And research on how the
anti-Semitic laws happened
it didn't happen until 16 years
after Mussolini came to power in 1938
was laws against the Jews proceeded
by colonial anti race racist laws in 1937.
And so it's very important
that the colonial context
that anti-Semitic laws
come in the middle of this
packet that was inspired
when the fascist went into Ethiopia
and this kind of set off a new phase
of feeling there was a racial emergency.
And Mussolini, newer
research has shown that
it wasn't just that Mussolini
was kind of tolerated Jews
and use them in a way that
Hitler would never have done.
Margherita Sarfatti, Mussolini's mistress
was very, very useful ally to him
in mainstreaming him and
getting him important context
with American diplomats,
very very early on,
but he also was, as
newer research has shown
a fierce anti-Semite of longstanding
and this was not made evident
for until fairly recently.
And so in 1936 already
he starts musing publicly in articles
that sometimes he doesn't
sign, but he writes them.
They're kind of anonymous.
And at one point this always struck me.
He said, I'll say it in Italian first.
(speaking in foreign language)
"The too much Jewishness
justifies anti-Jewishness."
So this is the classic
that Jews are having too much influence.
And so we are legitimated to
take measures against them.
And of course the anti-Semitic laws drew
on the Nurnberg laws in Germany.
But again, they're part of
this kind of larger packet
of defending racial prestige.
And what's interesting
is because fascist Italy
had plenty of church anti Judaism
and Catholic traditions of antisemitism.
It did not have the
political anti-Semitism
and the pogroms of Eastern Europe.
So propaganda became very, very important
if we are always looking with
the authoritarian playbook
how propaganda works together
with the other tools.
So propaganda took on a
highly, an elevated importance
it was a very intense
campaign over these few years
because there wasn't as much
of a tradition of violence
and discrimination against Jews
in the way there were was in
Eastern Europe, certainly.
And this will be familiar to many of you.
This the Jew is criminal, but you know
effective propaganda we'll
use we'll blend together
many different slogans
and tropes and fears.
So the Jew is also a communist
and these are him being defamed.
This is banks, this is the stock market.
So he's controlling everything
and he's being justly disciplined
and his threat is being cut off.
There's also, of course
it's like castration
there's all kinds of things going on.
That's a very economical image.
And the national purity is
very interesting for this.
This was the defense of the race.
It was the major, very
interesting surreal images
in this periodical and
in early scholarship,
when there was difficulty in
wanting to accept antisemitism
as part of fascism
it was deemed an extremist publication
later it comes out that it's published
by the ministry of national education
and the people, all the editors
are within the university system
as researchers, et cetera.
But here we have David of course
and with the fingerprint
of Jewish criminality.
So this is a very good example
of the outsider, the Jew,
who's also inside ruining and polluting
this Christian heritage, right?
So that's a very stark image.
And then we're going to come back to this.
Just another example
where the global dimension is important.
So these are kind of Blacks of Harlem.
And here is a Jew who the
kind of very the trope
of they can seem civilized
but they're actually barbaric.
So he's got some things
to do with a tuxedo
and then underneath,
he's got the grass skirt.
Let's see, make sure I have my time.
So these kinds of projects
obviously continued,
and there's no time here to trace out
all the post-war antisemitism.
What I want to do is just
touch on Berlusconi Italy
and touch on Trump.
And when Berlusconi,
he's very, very important
in the history of strongmen
and national purity projects.
He lays down a template
which leaders like Trump
not consciously borrowed from,
but he laid down this path 1994.
And then in the 2000s
he brings the far right into government
and eventually his party, Forza Italia,
fuses and merges with the far right party.
So he legalizes and legitimates
and mainstreams extremist tendencies.
He revives these kinds
of demographic anxieties
and the program Forza
Italia was "Catholic faith,
nation, Patriot, family, and order"
which is a classic right
wing authoritarian program.
And there was a lot of talk
of again, demographic crisis
which is perennial in Italy
and the center left governments
of course also worried
about demographic emergency
but in the Berlusconi governments
it was wedded to demonizing
migrants, detaining migrants.
Berlusconi was one of the first
to have large scale detentions of migrants
legitimating the far right.
And so you had extremist people
who were really on the fringes
with direct ties back to, you know
Neo fascism who now were in parliament.
So all of this process of
mainstreaming is happening.
And of course the revisioning of history.
So in an interview in
2003 to Boris Johnson
now prime minister and Nicholas Farro,
a right wing historian Berlusconi said,
Mussolini never killed anyone.
He just sent people into confinement
to have vacations,
referring to these islands
like Ponza where actually
torture was practiced.
So the whole packet of
what became the far right
demographic and racial anti migrant,
Berlusconi kind of sets
this up right early on.
And so now we come to
Trump and I have up here,
this is the former
representative, Steve King,
who is a liaison with the European right.
And this is a tweet where
he quotes approvingly
the Dutch rightist group fielders.
He understands that culture
and demographics are destiny.
"We can't restore our civilization
with somebody else's babies"
and justifiably there's
been huge amount of tension
attention paid to the
ties of the GOP and Russia
and which is another place
a hotbed of right-wing nationalism.
But I think we still need to understand
the integration of the GOP
with the far right politicians
and representative King was just one case
among many, in fact.
So as many of you will be aware,
racism was an axis of
Trump's national project
and a space in which confederate fetishism
mingled with people who never accepted
the end of segregation, anti immigration,
fears of, "The Browning of America".
And this started during the campaign
where he signaled to far right access.
When I started writing about Trump
when he retweeted Neo Nazi
means about black criminality,
starts using swastikas.
He starts re-tweeting images
of monkeys trying to cross the
border, open racist images.
And here's the famous, crooked
Hillary with the dollar bills
and the star that his people
claimed was a sheriff star
and not a Jewish star.
So very, very obvious
attempts at mainstreaming.
What was already there:
racism, antisemitism
anti-democratic tendencies,
extremism, all of that.
So it makes perfect sense
in the strongman world
that the man whose daughter and son-in-law
are observant Jews would also
be the one to praise neo-Nazis
of Charlottesville as very fine people.
And he's played a double
game while in office
pursuing Orthodox Jews successfully
with a pro Israel policy,
while increasing distrust of American Jews
with comments about their dual loyalties
and their Homeland really being Israel.
And of course the national
purification project
rears its head which played itself out
with increased hate crimes,
increased anti-Semitism,
increased hate crimes against Muslims
and especially anti-immigration policy
and spearheaded by Stephen Miller
a Jew connected to far right
networks for many, many years.
And as I argue in
"Strongmen", the intensity
of the Trump administration's efforts
to undo decades of
progress and integration
and somehow turn the
demographic clock back
really resembles earlier
right-wing counter revolutions.
And if we factor in all that
happened to the civil service
we haven't even begun to process
the scope of and the fury
of what happened within
government as well.
So by now, he's out of office
but antisemitic linked tropes
and images fled from many directions.
And we have QAnon is
getting a lot of attention
as a conspiracy theory and which draws on
the same kind of paranoia's
of Jews dominating the world
and murdering children,
it's not specifically directed at Jews
but many of the people espousing
it are also antisemites
also say things about Jews
and this kind of paranoid.
When this paranoid a
worldview is increasing.
So are other forms of intolerance.
So I'm just gonna end
with these last images
very disturbing from
the film that was shown
at the rally on January 6,
that proceeded the assault on the Capitol.
And there's a chain of images
that bring up the classic
idea of a cabal, right?
So here we have the Hollywood sign.
That's the very one of the first images
that the rally goers saw.
And here we have Chuck
Schumer wearing a Kente cloth.
And this connects back to the Jew
who's also somehow degenerate racially,
and the background for these
images of Hollywood and Schumer
here the text is the narrator is saying,
"For too long, a small group
in our nation's capital
has reaped the rewards of government
while the people have born the costs.
So the cabal again, and of course
the first and last images of this film
are straight out of
authoritarian leader calls.
This is what people saw that stayed
on screen as the rally dispersed.
And they started to go toward the Capitol.
And I will stop there.
- Thank you so much, that really gives us
a lot to discuss here.
We actually saw the same image.
Jason Stanley, who spoke
to us a couple of weeks ago
also showed the image of
Schumer and the Kente cloth.
So just to remind people
if you have a question and we hope you do
please submit it using
the Q and A function
at the bottom of your screen,
don't raise your hand.
We're not seeing those, or don't
write anything in the chat.
So we already have a bunch of questions.
And I know Carolyn and I both
have a bunch of questions too.
So I think I'll start with this
question from the audience,
"As you describe it, your
book emphasizes the continuity
between strongmen from
Mussolini to the present.
Can you also talk about how they differ?
I'm thinking of the frequent mention today
of liberal democracies
or sophisticated autocrats
who rely on the vocabulary
of democracy without
respecting the thing itself?"
- Yeah, that's a great question.
And one of the...
I felt it was really important to go back
and look back over a century
of authoritarian history,
because when people the
word fascism is back
people are comparing both
scenario or Trump to fascists.
And as a historian, I
really wanted to go back
and give each specific period it's due,
look at the through lines
but really respect those differences in.
So the whole first part of the
book is how they get to power
and each period.
So, you know, fascist era is one thing.
Military coups is a
totally different thing.
So today I make it really clear and also
in every chapter that I call
it new authoritarianism.
And this is where you come to
power, mostly by elections.
You manipulate elections to
stay there and information.
For example, with propaganda
it's really interesting
how much stays the same
like the cannons personality cults
they really haven't changed,
but of course, social
media and kind of soups up
and accelerates everything
to do with propaganda
because propaganda works
on saturation on repetition
on the same message with tiny variations.
And this is what social media does best.
So there's that tension
between what is different
and what is the same.
And another thing is the
way that there's a chapter
on resistance and the way
that resistance is practiced
is also helped by social media today.
So that for example, the classic image
from other eras of authoritarianism
of the police banging down,
they're banging on the door
of the resistor and the
resistor has to hide
his or her documents, right?
In the past we wouldn't see this,
we'd hear about it in memoirs or exiles
now in Putin's Russia, for
example, it's, live-streamed
by the resistor and they
create these communities
of empathy and one
dissident, he live streams
on Twitter he videoed his hard drive,
being flown out by a drone.
He sent his drone to his friend's house.
And so on Twitter, everybody
watched the drone leave
with his hard drive,
carrying it to safety.
So that's an example of how things change.
- Great. Carolyn, I don't
know if you want to jump in.
- I actually do.
I kind of have a follow-up to that,
that question which you
answered so clearly.
A larger framework in a
smaller one really briefly.
You talked about the
importance of efficiency
trains running on time obviously
Hitler built the Autobahn
and this kind of thing.
And it seems...
and obviously this coexists
with this new kind of media
presence, et cetera, et cetera
that these strongmen have
but it strikes me
that the signature of
authoritarian leaders,
at least in, say, I'd
begin, Bolsonaro or Trump
is kind of a, this chaos and anarchy
and I kind of wondered how
you make sense of that.
And then really briefly
the larger framework again,
is it, you also, you pointed out
that this all really takes
off in, I presume the '90s
at the end of the cold
war with these so-called
triumph of liberal capitalist democracy,
whereas fascism in the '20s and '30s
is clearly born of the
collapse of liberal,
whatever version of liberal
capitalism existed then.
And I wondered if how
that, if that's important,
this is in this strain
of difference, I guess.
- Yeah, one of the, the
macro themes of the book
was to bust this myth of
authoritarian efficiency.
And I wanted to...
throughout the book in each chapter
I focus on the chaos
on the destructiveness.
So what we know, for example,
from those who study,
who know the fascist antisemitism,
the plundering of assets,
how Jews had to give up their assets,
the state seize their assets, right,
and gave them, you know, very
little back or nothing at all.
This is one phase in a
plundering of business,
so we hear that authoritarian
is great for business, right,
because it brings stability.
Well, it's very good for
certain big business,
if you're in the oil industry or weapons,
like the sectors that
strongmen care about,
it's good for you.
Like with Trump, Big Pharma mining,
but business as a whole
and small business has been decimated
over and over again around
the world by strongmen.
And that's very important
and we don't hear enough about that.
So Putin, for example has jailed
tens of thousands of businessmen
because if your company does
too well, he goes after it
and it's this phenomenon
known as predation,
predator, you know, to be a predator.
So authoritarian States not
surprising our predatory States.
And we don't, we hear about the violence
of the predatory violence
and what they do to bodies
locking them up and killing them.
We don't hear what they do to capital.
We don't hear how they ruin, you know
family businesses that have
been there for decades, right,
for generations and the same
is true in Erdogan's, Turkey.
We're over $32 billion worth of assets
and schools and businesses
have been seized by Erdogan,
so this is part of it.
The other thing just quickly
is their governance
structure is highly chaotic
with constant recycling of people.
Even like somebody like Pinochet,
who seemed like, the famous picture of him
with the dark glasses,
he seemed statuesque,
he seemed stable.
He reshuffled his government
like over 40 times.
So, because nobody's loyal enough,
because of the same things
we've lived through with Trump,
this is classic, it's constant chaos.
And in fact, some of them
like Gaddafi and Idi Amin,
they really, psychologically
they thrived on chaos
and chaos is a psychological weapon
in all these States, whether
they wreck democracy or not,
it's constant scandal, constant outrage,
constant chaos of one form or another
and it's exhausting to people,
even if their life's not at
risk as in a true dictatorship.
It's exhausting and authoritarianism plays
on us being exhausted from the chaos.
- So interesting and here's
a question from the audience
and something that I think
has occurred to a lot of us,
Trump famously doesn't read,
he's not a student of history,
so where does he...
how did he so perfectly follow
all of this authoritarian models,
is it instinctual for him
or how did he do this?
- Yeah, it's so interesting
because he really does follow it.
I mean, I was able to predict
almost everything he did
and the GOP's response,
not because I'm psychic
but because I have studied this stuff
and I'm always upset that I'm right.
I would love to be wrong
but I haven't been wrong, unfortunately.
And this is because number one,
they have similar personalities.
And so they structure their governance
in similar ways with which
produces similar results.
So for example, all of them
have these inner sanctums,
I call them also cocoons with
sycophants and family members,
it's very important to have sons in law,
I have a whole paragraphs on sons-in-law
from Ciano, Mussolini up to Jared Kushner
and these are because they
can't have any proper feedback.
So that's one example.
Also the impulsiveness, the
chaos, the vindictiveness
all of that is the same
and so it leads to similar outcomes.
Now, Trump is indeed, he is different
than everybody who came before
him because he doesn't read.
So of course there...
but none of them, there is no manual
although they do watch
what each other does.
So Hitler learned from Mussolini,
he studied him very closely
and they also watch very
carefully how they fall.
So when Gaddafi saw what
happened to Saddam Hussein
he actually changed his policies
and cooperated with the
West because he said,
"I'm not going to end up
being dragged out of a hole."
Which is actually what happened to him.
But then when that happened to him,
Putin became very
obsessed with Arab spring
and he watched over and over again
the footage of Gaddafi being killed.
And he then had his own crackdown, 2012.
He started, he came back to the presidency
but he really cracked down
and he had mass protests.
But this was also because he was worried
that Arab spring would
spell the end for him.
So it's instinct, it's
personality similarities
but it's also, there is
some monitoring going on.
- So interesting, so here's a
question from our colleague,
Sam Moines who says, "This brilliant Ruth,
but I'm wondering how we avoid sweeping
with too broad a brush
and stigmatizing legitimate,
or even uplifting
political arguments or worse,
for example, it has to be
legitimate to call out elites
and I've never seen a more
utopian moment in this country
than when Barack Obama was
running, but I'm left unsure
whether you think such
things are too dangerous
given scary talk of cabals or
right-wing utopian discourse."
- For the detailed response, read the book
but calling for good
example, calling out leads.
So, because they're also different kinds,
I don't use the word populism too much,
because populism is an
ideology used by Mussolini
and it's there are populous parties
but a lot of the authoritarians
are not populous.
Like Pinochet was not
a populist for example,
but calling out elites
can be very solitary,
can be very healthy,
except when authoritarians
and a lot of these populous
parties are doing it today,
it's a foe calling out because
in fact one of the biggest
hypocrisy that exists is the
idea of the anti globalist,
that whole rhetoric of anti globalist,
because who is a bigger
globalist than Trump.
His whole business model
was licensing his name all over the world.
He and Ivanka even today
have Chinese trademarks
or Putin and think of the post-communist
version of anti globalism, which
involves calling out elites
Western elites.
They all have their money,
their illicitly gained money stored
in offshore finance networks,
which are mostly in the West.
So these are the biggest
globalists that there are.
So, this is why the kind
of toolbox is important
because propaganda or rhetorical themes
such as anti-elitism,
when they're married with corruption
which is what I've been talking about
with ex filtrating assets, like Putin does
to globalist havens.
When you see it in that frame
and you don't take only one of them,
when you keep them in
their kind of context,
then there's nothing salutary about that.
That's just corruption
and that's the basis of authoritarianism.
- So a question from another
colleague, from Katie Truppner,
who'd like to hear more
about the historic links
between Mussolini and Hitlerian
fascism and imperialism.
And also whether you see
similar geopolitical aspirations
among strongmen today,
like the revanchist
nostalgia for lost empires,
like Greater Hungary
or the Ottoman empire,
things like that.
- So for the first part of
Italian fascism and imperialism,
so, we actually don't know know enough
about the global reach of Italian fascism,
but what is very interesting
is that the model of empire
that Mussolini was propagating
was a little bit different
because Mussolini wanted
to do territorial expansion
and he did, eventually in
the Balkans in World War II
but he also wanted to
recuperate for the empire
the little Italy's around the world,
this kind of soft power, soft imperialism
that involved the diaspora.
And in this, as in so many other things,
Mussolini is linked to better than Hitler
to 21st century authoritarians,
such as Modi or Duterte
who make a big...
they're not invading territory
'cause that's less common today,
but they are using a diaspora
to have a sense of a greater nation.
In fact, the chapter in the book
is called 'A Greater Nation.'
And it deals with these themes of exile,
these themes of calling
out to the diaspora,
as well as you have an Erdogan
who's like, aggressive,
and de-stabilizing because of his desire.
And he says, very clearly,
Turkey's empire should go...
he includes territories that
are now part of Greece, right?
So, there's something there
what's one way, for example
that Trump is not a fascist at all,
is that he is interested in
kind of plundering the state,
which they did, but a lot of
them today are not interested
in territorial expansion,
I mean, Putin is,
but sometimes the rhetoric
of the greater nation,
it less frequently translates
into armed aggression.
And for this reason, it also
plays more on the diaspora.
- So a couple of people are really,
wondering about Trump's Jewish
children that you referred to
and one person said, how
can he be called a fascist
or a strong man or antisemitic
if he has Jewish children
and grandchildren and then
other people just want to hear
more about what you meant
when you said that actually
makes him stronger in a sense
to be able to claim that link?
- So the issue of him having
a daughter who converted
to orthodoxy because of
Jared it means nothing.
Strongmen are completely
amoral and transactional.
So Mussolini also, he
was a huge anti-Semite
and he ended up, you know,
sending Jews to their deaths.
And he had a Jewish mistress
when he needed to have one
because she was useful to him
and it's the same as,
you know, people who say
they're not racist because
they had a black lover,
it's a misplacement of the question.
What is very interesting
is Trump's ability
as one of the most profane
and unbiased individuals
was able to be the one who
was acclaimed by Orthodox Jews
and by the angelical Christians
as ruling with a divine mandate.
And this goes back to Mussolini
who no one was more anti-clerical
and atheist than Mussolini
and yet he was the one who
solved the church state question
and created Vatican city
and got the Pope to say
he's there by the will of providence.
So this is this transactional.
They will be whatever you need them to be,
they will ally with anyone
they need to ally with
and Trump has delivered for Orthodox Jews
with moving the embassy
and he has delivered hugely
for evangelical Christians.
So it's no wonder that they say
that he's been put in office
by the will of God.
So if we look at a kind of personality
who's completely amoral
and yet is so skilled at
connecting with people
and has this particular kind
of manipulative charisma
to be embraced as a
leader of a certain type,
they are also the ones who
have these crazy alliances
like Berlusconi too.
He was hugely misogynist
and yet one of his biggest
basis was housewives.
So there's always this
question of how can people
back someone who does this,
it unfolds in different arenas
with this kind of ruler.
- So I'm curious how you
would respond to a question
that we're getting about
illiberal tendencies on the left.
So, you know, so-called cancel culture
or the movement to shut down, you know
conservative opinion as so-called.
So do you see this, what
would you say to someone
who says, Oh, the left does this too.
- I mean, it depends
what you mean by this.
Yes, there are many people
who write to me who are irate
because I don't have Chavez
or Castro in my book.
And they see that as somehow implicitly
I'm saying that only the
right does these things.
So, which is, of course I had
my reasons for only deciding
as we all do have our reasons
to delimit our projects
in certain ways.
But I mean, the cancel culture
thing is very interesting
because it's being used most
effectively by the right.
And I have a picture in
my book from the 1920s
it's a Nazi party propaganda poster
of Hitler being canceled of
Hitler with a taped mouth
because in the twenties,
after he got out of jail
for his push, there was a
ban on him speaking in public
cause it was hate speech.
And so the Nazis responded
by making him into a canceled hero.
And so there were many posters
they put out with his mouth taped,
and one of them says of all the people,
I'm the one who's forbidden to speak.
And this was highly effective
at making Hitler into a Maverick
and a truth teller who was
silenced by the establishment.
So what I could say about
the liberal tendencies
of the left is that, in
times of polarization,
you do see similar tendencies
of people fearing that
they're being canceled.
And it's a symptom of also a kind of,
voiding and death of a center, right?
And so that's a huge problem
in the States right now.
There's, polarization
is really accelerating,
and that's very very bad as we know.
- Okay, so maybe one more
question from the audience
and then I'll give
Carolyn the last question.
So first one more question
from the audience, which is,
we talked about how Trump doesn't read
and that it's sort of instinctual
or part of his personality
that he's picking up on these things.
But do you also draw a instinction
or could you say a little bit more,
between those elements like
people and I'm thinking here,
people like Bannon or Stephen Miller,
who probably are reading
and are explicitly learning,
this is William Quack's
question here about,
are there some who are actually
studying the fascist playbook explicitly?
- Yeah, another reason I
don't call Trump a fascist is,
actually, fascism isn't
enough to capture the scope
of the knowledge and
wisdom of around Trump.
Meaning, Trump has been
surrounded by people
like Roger Stone, who
has decades of experience
and wisdom about how to
take down democracies.
And Roger Stone and Paul Manafort,
worked for Mobutu in the
Congo, whose in my book.
They worked for Ferdinand
Marcos, they were hired.
I have their Foreign Agents
Registration Act paper.
They were hired by Marcos in the 80s,
to kind of oversee his
fraudulent election.
So Roger Stone is one example.
There are people around Trump,
who have a wealth of authoritarian,
history and knowledge,
that is way bigger than fascism.
So it's actually more scary
if anything could be scarier than fascism.
The same with Bannon.
I mean, Bannon is a fan
of all things fascists,
but he is, he even moved to Europe.
I mean, he is firmly
immersed in the global right
in a way that transcends
fascia, historic fascism.
So when we talk about,
there's many reasons
not to call Trump a fascist,
although Trump and co,
Trump and colleagues obviously take things
from the fascist era, absolutely, right?
And so, in fact, as Jason
Stanley's book shows
there are continuity's in these things.
So that's why many people say, well,
Trump is what fascism looks like now.
I prefer to use the word authoritarian,
because he may not be reading,
but the people around him
are steeped in knowledge,
of anti-democratic
action, of theory, of
psychological warfare,
that's very important for Roger Stone
and many people around Trump,
including people who stormed the capital.
Some of the military
who stormed the capital
they were trained in PSYOPs,
psychological warfare.
And Bannon in fact, S. Miller and Bannon,
when they came into power
and they did the ban on
travel from Muslim countries,
this was a classic
authoritarian shock event.
It's when my book, I
talk about shock events.
Authoritarians love shock events,
and they create windows of chaos.
This is what the question about chaos.
This was preparing, this
was a psychological warfare
as well as a bureaucratic warfare.
It was telling people that
chaos will be a feature
and not a bug of the Trump presidency,
and that government will
be used against you.
And so this is why it's
much bigger than fascism,
remnants of fascism, scarily, so.
- Great, Carolyn if you want
to ask the last question here?
Oh, you're muted Carolyn.
- Yeah, sorry there we go.
I just had just two, I
guess wrap up questions
looking toward the future,
given that I'm sure,
well, a lot of us were thinking
about some of these issues
and one of the things you've
talked about so effectively,
is how cancel culture,
is a common feature of say
regimes in the 30s and now,
except that now we have social media,
and I was thinking about
Marjorie Taylor Greene,
or someone like that, who
goes on the floor of Congress,
has tons of a huge audience,
but then, that has
censored across her mask,
and that creates the reality.
And I wonder can you talk about,
how, if it's a peculiarly
American phenomena,
or how the Stones and
Manafort and Trump himself
have all created an illusion that
it is the left?? that is
imposing upon our liberties.
I'm just, is that American,
is that a fascism,
and is that sort of
important, do you think,
to thinking about the kind
of new authoritarianism
in the United States since
American exceptionalism
may have been shattered
by Trump's presidency?
Nonetheless, there is still this,
a commitment to liberty
or the use of these
the deployment of liberty
as a really important theme.
And I just wondered if
you could talk about,
as a way or just thinking about where,
what we should think about,
what we should be looking
for going forward?
That's just one thing I've
just been really struck by
in this whole thing.
- Yeah, not only is not
American particular to America,
it's the oldest,
and Mussolini when he
was theorizing fascism
one of the main things was that,
that form of liberty was tyranny.
And there are things
that he said about why
democracy is actually a
tyranny that are almost
a 100% echoed by Orban in Hungary,
that liberal democracy becomes a tyranny.
They don't always flesh out
the truly fascistic endpoint today,
in their speeches out loud.
They don't always say the
ending out loud, today.
And Orban has his own catchphrases
right about electoral autocracies
and this kind of keeping the electoral in
or the democracy part in allows
them to have it's a scandal,
why does Orban have EU funding?
This should not be, he's
ruling by decree now.
But there's always been this,
but so this whole heritage
of political theory
that goes from the idea
of liberties as tyranny and
that we're being censored
and we're being canceled
in our personhood,
it goes back to the inter-war period
the feeling that mass
society in both the communist
and the American capitalist
materialist vision
was extinguishing personhood.
It was extinguishing spirituality.
And so fascism became
this kind of third way.
This was a very popular slogan
that the fascist came up with.
They would be the, they
would preserve individuality,
they would preserve freedom,
but within a structure,
unlike the anarchy of liberal democracy
and the massification
that can become a tyranny.
So it's a history of rights being curbed,
It's many people in your
audience, written about this.
But there's nothing
particularly American about it.
The only thing that is, the
thing that is more enhanced
and emphasized in America,
is the particular way given
to individualism and guns,
gun ownership as a symbol of that.
'Cause American is
exceptionalism is not democracy,
it's gun ownership to the point
where people have arsenals,
that are only seen in peace,
they're never seen in peace time.
Putin doesn't have, let
people have private citizens
have huge arsenals.
So that is something.
and I find it very telling that,
there's been relative silence
of all that's been written
about January 6th and extremism.
There haven't been that
many articles about guns.
'Cause extremist is
nothing without the guns,
without his arsenal or her arsenal.
So the liberty...
So if you trying to ease out
what is particularly American about
this discourses that are
happening under been legitimized
by the GOP and they will go forward,
Trump's not in office
anymore, but they are.
Its very scary that it dates back
to a whole history of illiberalism.
- Okay, well, on that
note, we're actually over
and I feel like we could go on all night,
but I encourage everybody to buy your book
and can learn just so much from it,
and to really thank you for
this wonderful talk today,
and for patiently answering
all of our questions
I encourage everyone in
the audience to sign up
for the YPSA mailing lists,
so you can find out about
future talks and please join me
in signing out at last, in
thanking professor Ben-Ghiat.
So thank you again.
- Thank you, thanks for the
great questions, everyone.